in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
a hearing loss in your mid forties dr.
miscellaneous this is a common problem
sure I see a lot of patients with these
problems they are coming just into my
office when they have problems during
the day when they just talk to each
other then they come into my office 24
Diagnostics so this is one of the first
symptoms that you can follow speeches
and conversation it's exactly that so
the typical situation if you are waiting
for example for a train or being outside
you're listening to the traffic and you
want to talk to somebody else this is a
typical situation where you have
problems then and if a patient comes to
you and says I've got some problems with
my hearing and what you do with them so
I just check the ear with my microscope
and then we do of course a lot of
diagnostic so we have a lot of machines
where we can do every test which is
which which you can imagine to check the
function of year so you check every
single part of the year starting from
the outer part until inner part of panic
membrane so we can check also the
ossicles inside and and the function of
the in a year what are the main causes
for the hearing loss so when you're
younger the main reasons are usually
inflammations for example a child if
you're a little bit older also chronic
inflammation can come up be an issue and
later if you're older so more than 65
years old forty percent of the people
have problems with hearing because of a
GJ degeneration of the inner ear cells
so sure it's normal way of life then
yeah that's physiological and can you do
anything about it no now up to now we
can't do anything about that and the
thing is that's not in every patient the
same thing as right as coming up usually
we have some patients being 65 having
problems others that start for the speed
these problem starts when you're 70 or
75 but if say Sam some younger person
comes to you and got love loss of
hearing can you do anything about this
thing if you are a younger and you have
a chronic inflammation for example then
we can do small interventions or a
surgery to solve the problems were
and you're putting some kind of implants
into the year 2228 the hearing process
of the patients and I think you've got
some implants here and so what do you do
with them exactly so we have some
different kind of implants so we have
implants which are replacing the
function of the middle ear so this is
just something like an implantable
hearing aid you can see here this small
thing this is looking like a small
tongue and if we put this just beside a
structure of the in a year then it can
transduce sound into the inner ear it's
something like an implantable hearing
aid and there are other implants if the
inner ear is not working anymore only
the nerve is working we can put this
under the skin and then for example this
electrode is implanted into the inner
ear and this can stimulate than the
nerve directly so it's like a back pass
because you're bypassing structures of
the year which don't work and go
directly into the nerve exactly exactly
that is that what we do these implants
if these cells are not working inside of
the inner ear we just replace it by this
implant because then the nervous
directly stimulated just like a
pacemaker but just an another function
so what part of this implant is inside
the ear and what part is outside the
inside of the patient is this part so we
put this under the skin and we put the
electrode inside of the in a year and
what the patient has to where is this
speech processor which is just working
in the same way like the hair cells it
is what you can see if you look at the
asian you can see the zig zag behind the
year this is behind the ear and this is
a coil which is just communicating with
the implant which is under the skin so
this is a hearing aid you can use if
some parts of the inner ear is damaged
or damaged when do you use normal
hearing it most of the patients need
normal hearing aids and it's always the
first way we have to choose for the
patients and if hearing aids are not
working anymore then these implants are
initial can you use these implants and
patients of any age yes these implants
can be used in nearly every age so we
start doing this kind of surgery at the
age of three months these are released
children and we can do it also on both
ears and one session and the main
portion of the patients are of course
elder patients about 60 70 years old and
there we are using always these implants
just on one side unilateral a children
grow in the end plans don't so you have
to remove them and change them over life
usually not because if you look to the
implants they have a coil which is long
enough so we put something like a
reserve the protocol inside of the ear
bone so if the cock-eyed is growing this
is just straightening more and more so
this is usually not a problem that this
is torn out of the in a year dr. miss it
and why is it so hard to treat tinnitus
so tonight is it something which is
arising in the inner ear if you have a
problem there a hearing impairment for
example then the sensation is coming up
and a process starch which is just
running around in the brain and this is
something which is very complex and not
easy to treat but if you would treat the
hearing impairment in the first place
could you prevent tinnitus for instance
we can't prevent it but we can cover it
if the hearing impairment is treated for
example by a hearing aid then most of
the patients have less complaints we've
got a lot of viewer questions for
instance from Nairobi checking is a DJ
and she wants to know how to protect her
hearing there is a way to protect it
there are special ear plugs on the
market you can buy and they are just
cutting off everything above 65 DB this
is just the level where we talk now so
this is then less dangerous for the year
so the cutting it off means that they're
bringing it down so that Jacqueline's
can still hear the music that she's
hearing it and listen there's a volume
exactly so this is a very comfortable
level this is the same situation like we
sit now here if we have if you have the
sound at that level it's it's very nice
for you to listen and you can listen to
everything what you would like and this
is practical because the djs like to
feel the drums like to hear the music
like the the dancer stood of course it's
practical but I know that the compliance
of the users / is very
it's very important because that they
don't need a hearing aid in the future
like zohan Cordia who wants to know why
his hearing aid is making funny sounds
typical situation is that a patient is
older more than 70 years old for example
to wearing hearing aids and the hearing
aid is not well adjusted so he needs to
go to the to the urologist or yeah he
usually has to check that as somebody
who gave him the hearing aid should
check technically the hearing aid and
this is and I think eighty percent of
the case is the problem but it doesn't
necessarily mean that the hearing it is
damaged no not just a just no problem
usually not okay peter allen quito from
finland wants to know if drugs can be
blamed to be the cause of hearing losses
I mean Jack's not like IV drugs what a
communication this is a very important
thing in daily life we know a lot of
medications which I can make which can
make problems there for example aspirin
if you take aspirin and a high dosage
those atras can make a problem in the in
a year but this is usually reversible
other drugs for example antibiotics
gentamicin gentamicin or for example
something which is used in thermo
chemotherapies then these effects can be
irreversible irreversible and then they
have problems within a year which should
be treated with other ways there's
nothing to do to prevent it because if
the doctor says we have to take this
chemotherapy you have to take it no
there's no way no way to do it another
way you need the chemotherapy and you
have to do it prevention of hearing loss
say in the elderly is there any way to
prevent the normal decay of hearing
losing the hearing and an elder people
is a normal and physiological process
sometimes that's starting earlier
sometimes later but this is something
which is coming up for everybody so
there's something we just have to adjust
to thank you dr. me Selim for inviting
me into your cleaning thank you
you